so like I had a trap house on top of my
grandma's house like I mean I grew up in
the streets so I don't think and and I
get along with the black women that I
date from my culture so that's not the
issue but I think
you know there are certain things like
girl trips
like that would never I would never that
doesn't happen
um going out to the club partying that
doesn't happen like it's unacceptable
right and so
and the women that I've dated
the past six like eight years they've
never done any of that and including the
black women that I've dated so there's a
certain
there's a certain culture so even the
black women that I've dated they're just
they're more simple right you know they
they want to travel to different
countries they want to be whined and
dined they want to feel pretty they want
money spent on them but they don't want
to go to the club they'd rather go to
Stockholm and go through a Michelin star
so it's a it's just a different
way of doing things
um whereas you know I've like dated a
girl she's like she wants to go on a
girl trip and I'm like absolutely not
like that I mean I just stopped talking
to her
would you say that
um like in your interactions you feel
like
you're not you're not fun enough
for a lot of black women you you don't
feel that they see you as a fun guy to
be with so that kind of causes a
disconnect you know it's a certain it's
a certain kind of fun because
you know it like the let's say
you know like trying Edibles or you know
doing Addy
like travel in different countries right
so like look like the folks that are
like the you know that people might
think are the stuffy ones their party
and the hardest they're doing the
hardest craziest stuff right so I you
know so I have fun but it's it's just
different like I would never be in the
club like I I just I would never go I've
never been you know I can't see over
anyone right so it's like I'm not going
to go to a club but you know I'll I'll
do other things with you
um let's go to a museum let's go to
Symphony Orchestra let's go you know do
something crazy just random fly to a
country
two days in advance just pick a random
country we're out all right that's my
fun you know go on I have to say please
let us not underestimate the value and
the importance of culture in our lives
because
Museum Symphony this that doesn't sound
like much that is actually related to
like the
you know the your true culture which is
what the other black women probably
looking for the women that you have met
is great because you found like-minded
people that have expanded and explored
outside of you know their General
culture I understand that because I've
done the same I mixed race so I can
understand how I can jump from culture
to culture but I still it Still Remains
so obviously you're explaining all of
these things and if I put my black and
straight African shoes on I'll be like
okay I get that but you're now making it
sound almost like there's an issue with
dancing there's an issue with all of
these things that actually is a black
person especially of African Heritage
which all we all are music The Rhythm
all of these things are things that
actually culture Even in our blood it
makes us feel different it's something
that we need to relate to we can try and
run away from this oh yeah it is the
21st century you can do this you can do
that but what is in you is in you so
that's why sometimes there may be a
disconnect because people probably
trying to see that element of your black
identity that comes from that side that
culture where they can relate to you and
probably understand you better so
obviously when you explain you've got
all of these things going on maybe just
you need to have more conversations with
these people and explain that you've
changed because you've grown and you've
been in different environments you still
have you still retain that you know some
of that cultural identity
um but obviously you've just evolved
that's all
I think there's a couple things
like how One black person say you're
going from a West Africa to East Africa
how you each identify a Black Culture
can be very different because Black
Culture isn't one thing just because
you're you're within the same skin tone
doesn't mean that you have the same
everything within your culture you don't
share everything secondly I think he's
speaking a lot more on preferences in
terms of like the types of things he
likes to do with women
any woman no matter what you look like
could have those preferences just
because you're ethnically boxed into a
stereotype doesn't mean that this is all
you can be and this is like if you're
not a part of this stereotype you're not
a part of us I think we're in a
generation now where
because of social media and all these
sort of things we have all this exposure
all these stereotypes have been pushed
out as characteristics and they've been
pushed out as things as if you're from
this culture or you're from this country
you're automatically like this so if if
I like um this type of West African man
and if he's not like this then in my
head you're not a West African man
you're more like a white man or you're
more like this type of man but even the
whole identification of like black
people white people
that was never that's not a thing back
home like you are you identify people by
their tribes by their culture of by
their by what country they're from by
you know who their parents are and what
their grandparents did and stuff like
that you don't purely identify Somebody
by the color of their skin and I think
this is something that's been put into
the West to separate and then to also
indoctrinate us within our own
communities so that now we have these
situations where you're not black enough
you're not African enough you're not
this enough you're not that enough and
we place those things and we put them as
if they were a part of our culture but
like I said Black Culture isn't just one
thing you can be you can be black and
come from two different parts of the
world and have a completely different
culture I wanna I wanna ask us I want to
change a piece I want to ask you a
question yeah like when whenever you
hear like black guys say
um I don't really date black women
because they got bad attitude what does
that make you think like do you think
they just are they're just making an
excuse or do you think there's an
element of Truth to that it makes me
feel like don't underestimate my
attitude like I can come I can come at
you crazy too like I don't think it's
something that is like a trait specific
to black women anyone can have an
attitude if they're having a bad day
like that's my yeah that's my perception
of it I don't think it kind of has
anything to do with race like you can
have white Karen's going around
screaming and having rants all the way
and so you see in social media all the
time in the states like it has nothing I
don't think it has anything to do with
the color of your skin it's your
attitude so you feel your personality so
you feel like when black guys say that
they're basically just just making up
excuses excuses do you would you agree
I think that we all all of us have been
like
I don't even know what the word is but
like taught to think that black women
are these like really angry people even
like down to just looking at black
women's sometimes people just like be
like they're angry and we're not so yeah
I think it's just a really deep-rooted
thing in all of us that we kind of need
to do you think do you think there could
be a chance that because this has been
engineered into us that there is a
percentage of black women that do as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible